we're gonna be training like Avengers
with 30 days yay
so what we mean when we say we're
training like the Avengers just means
that we're training like the actors when
they're preparing for their roads no
poison spiders
where does hitting the gym for 30 days
our trainer was Shawn he actually did
his homework he went out and found out
exactly what these actors do you found
out how they ate what their workout
regiment was and regular people who are
going to try to emulate exactly that for
the next 30 days they're all gonna be
training like our favorite Avengers and
none of these 30 days we're gonna be
ready to save the universe or do a
push-up that's a plan anyways hey guys
my name is how and I'm going to be
training like Thor
I chose Thor because one I don't know
how to lift weights I like to run and I
like to be active but I've never lifted
a weight in my life and two he's really
hot so hey what's up on the day and I'm
gonna be training like His Majesty King
deshyla aka Black Panther I don't just
want to work out like Black Panther I
wanna be Black Panther if I can get my
body into shape then my mind will soon
follow the reason I chose spider-man I
mean obviously spider-man is super cool
but more than anything because recently
into the spider verse came out and I
think it is really cool that in this
multi universe anybody can see spiders
no matter what race what nationality if
anybody campus spider-man I guess I give
the spider-man
I chose Captain Marvel
I was a following very Larson on
Instagram and she was posting all these
crazy videos of her workouts and then I
heard an interview about how she could
barely open water bottles before she
started preparing for this role and I
was like she can do it maybe I can do it
which might not be true but we're gonna
find out
I clearly excited because I'm really
good friends with Halliday and Ashley
you know we have this like an official
Marvel movie fan club it's really cute
we like go to watch Marvel movies
together we talk about it afterwards it
would be nice get in courage men cheer
each other on and become superheroes
while we're at it are you ready yes yes
I'm ready okay let's go see Sean so high
tech hey guys I'm rashon and I'm a
fitness professional at Equinox not only
am i fitness professional but I'm a huge
Marvel fan so I know what it takes to
get these guys to the characters that
they want to be Black Panther is known
for his hand-to-hand combat skills and
it's super strength
so today's program is gonna involve a
lot of hit circuit style training boxing
the martial arts in there and of course
cardio so actually wants to be Captain
Marvel she's got her work cut out for
Captain Marvel is the strongest
character so far seen on screen so that
program is going to involve resistance
training three times a week with RTL two
times just to top it off anchor is
training to be spider-man and spider-man
is really really agile fast and lean so
anchors program is going to involve a
lot of body weight and TRX training and
finally we've got how that wants to
train like Thor so his programs are
gonna involve a lot of barbell complexes
dumbbell apparatus just like the king of
Asgard
[Applause]
week one was one of the most grueling
intensive weeks I've ever had in my
entire life we just finished our kickoff
session with Rashad put a lot of work to
do to get a point A to point Z I'm
really tired but I can see that this I
think it's gonna work so at this point
I'm thinking maybe it's not that bad
then second training with hell that's a
little bit different day two of training
and already I have been defeated by the
Machine thoroughly defeated we watch old
mr. Hemsworth's videos of him like
punching the bag and I'm just thinking
to myself this is laughable but I'm
trying to do this the content is he so
time Holland you just think he's like
this little kid who just like swings
around and I was a little bit silly but
then like I'm doing all these workouts
and I'm also looking at the workout
videos he did and it is absolutely
insane he's like flipping around like oh
where did you get all those muscles from
it takes so much effort to build up all
this core strength an arm straight I
honestly expected my workout to be a lot
of cardio I did not realize how much
weightlifting I would actually have to
do brie Larson is a very thin person and
in my head I associated weightlifting
with big bulky people like Thor but
that's not necessarily true there's so
many ways to weight lifts so I'm really
happy that rashon has opened my eyes
because on my own I would have never
done this do I like to call an alligator
walk I'm gonna be running every day
boxing if this is what it takes to get
in the shape that Chadwick Boseman has
some in its week too
I've learned all the movements now it's
time to get down to business and Michael
really put in the work week - it was
almost as tough as week one because I'm
working through all the pain that
one gave me honestly the workouts in
itself I'm like it's really difficult
but I can do it I just need to put my
mind to it that part is taken care of
the hard thing is my mom is also in town
my mom just made a bunch of dumplings
you know when your parents are here
you're supposed to entertain them you're
supposed to take them to awesome
restaurants and eat a lot and I was like
I can't do any of that made me think
about how you know that all these actors
and actresses when to preparing for a
row I'm sure they're invited to a lot of
events I'm sure they have parents
visiting too and they have these
gatherings with friends and it's so hard
to you know to be strict with yourself
the key here is that they have to
sacrifice a lot it's not it's really not
easy at all
[Music]
I am so hungry I have never had so many
protein shakes in my life trying to feel
my body with only healthy things like
Bree did but day it is so hard also it's
kind of expensive to eat healthy all the
time look at where Ashley's doing
there's a lot of barriers for regular
people to achieve this Hollywood
lifestyle there you're eating out
expensive salads every day or you are
meal prepping for like three hours on
Sunday if I'm feeling the pressure to
eat soup and salad but inka eat Cheerios
work out and just be focused I can only
imagine what it's like for a Hollywood
superstar to be featured in a superhero
movie I have the pressure of youtube
they have the pressure of an entire
industry that throws millions and
dollars that though but also think it
paid millions of dollars and I just got
a free gym membership for 30 days low
point for week 3 was vomiting or Shawn
made us push him on this like film block
back and forth and they did it a lot and
it was really having a really hard I did
not eat before this workout with Inca
and I ended up dry heaving over the
garbage game but I will definitely be
having full meals from now on because I
never want to be like that again my butt
literally hurt I could not sit for 25
minutes climb stairs there's so much to
wet coming down
[Music]
okay today we got one more week how you
feeling I don't want to jinx it but I
feel so good I think the biggest
difference is my mood I'm so happy and I
just feel really motivated not just with
the working out but with everything else
I'm doing when you start your day at the
gym giving yourself some time and giving
your body some attention it just puts
you in the right headspace for the rest
of the day also just the biological
effects of working out I think the
endorphins are really helping me out in
all aspects of my life I'm hoping it all
adds up by the end of the week it is my
last run before day 30 and I'd much
rather be doing this but we're gonna get
it done do you want to come on a run
with me that's enough I'm starting to
really get into rhythm of things I feel
like we really started like a routine
like I love being able to come to work
and then asking either Ashley a day or
how's like how do workout go how do you
feel you know that are you going to the
gym later do you want to go to a class
together like I really like that sort of
camaraderie that was probably the best
part of everything it really felt like
we were all our own little like Avengers
team well almost there I want the
results I need to drop these lbs I need
to increase these I don't even know the
abbreviation for muscles I gotta
increase these muscles I'm super excited
we're almost there I'm so close to being
able to eat what I want oh I'm so pumped
and
I'm so ready to get this done
[Music]
okay they so before your wing then at
265 pounds also you are at 32 percent
body fat so let's see where you are now
[Music]
good very very impressive our anger so
this is very very exciting when we
started you were 28% body fat
now you're 24 okay how you ready yeah I
don't think previously you'll apply 103
pounds of press okay so now you apply a
27 more pounds of pressure in just 30
days this is the crazy part okay
so your dominant hand right before you
were applying between 73 and 74 pounds
of pressure so now you able to apply
that's awesome for Thor I feel like I
accomplished my goals I learned how to
lift weights gained some confidence in
the gym and then also I just what out
got stronger I guess I didn't really
realize how much work went into looking
like a superhero
fancy trainers meal plans yeah those are
there but you still have to put in the
work to make it happen so it's really
impressive how that view is in videos
maybe somebody will see me in a skirt
you know Thor 2.0 how how Thor I'm not
gonna combine this see there Fowler hor
and both of those sounds terrible yeah
the results are honestly super
encouraging in the beginning I said
anybody
the spider-man and after this experience
I will stand by that statement I really
do think that if you put your mind to it
change can happen you don't need to be
starring in a movie or a YouTube video
to do anything like this I set a goal
for yourself give yourself a deadline
and you can make it you know growing up
a lot of people admire all of these
actors and their physiques but this
experience gave me a peek behind the
curtain I realized that it's almost
impossible to be a regular person and
work out like one of these superheroes I
had no idea what the regiments were or
the eating plans these actors had to go
through don't hold yourself to Hollywood
standards it's not impossible but just
very difficult it's not always about
numbers it's about treating your body
right so that you can do amazing things
whether that's preparing for a role
you're just having a motivation to do
every
regular people thanks to yeah I don't
have a movie that I'm training for but
feeling better about myself and having
more energy and has only helped me brie
Larson trained for like nine months I
did this for 30 days so I'm really happy
with the result and I'm really motivated
to keep going
[Music]